so we have our hipster shop app and
we've been talking a lot about SEO but
when you have sto managing
micro-services why would we need API
management and added sure I give this
question all the time in simple words is
too is great to manage micro-services
but when the developers decide to shake
those services to other teams or
external developers they need to publish
an API the successful API needs to be
easily consumed
that's very peer management concept with
Apogee you can easily employ standard
API management capabilities
sounds like a helpful set of features
can you show me how I can get this set
up sure let me show how it works
let's use hipster shop app for the demo
if the shop app is a tender
micro-services application if the based
app where users can browse items add
them to the cart and purchase them which
is running entirely on communities and
manage may steal this is the service
architecture of the Future Shop app so
far the shipping service is utilized
only by the internal micro services now
we want to expose the shipping service
as a tracking API to the third-party
developers so they can take advantage of
a service let's go back and expose the
shipping services tracking API using
this virtual service tracking in the API
path is pointed to the shipping service
which is running on kubernetes once the
service is created let's access the API
to see if it is created successfully and
we can retrieve the tracking details of
the tracking ID once the necessary RPG
provisioning is taken care of these
definitions here are to configure the
epidemic certain Sto so that we can
start using the cap builders let's look
at some of the things we can do in
aperture this configuration tells his
geo to send all the required attributes
to mixer for each transaction which will
be forward to a PG for analytics
reporting and applied routes to traffic
flowing through this is just Aris mesh
once the configurations are said let's
create a rule to capture analytics for
all the inbound calls to the micro
services this records all the aboard
defined fields and follow us to a PG for
analytics reporting let's go to the a PG
management UI to access the outer box
reports to view the metrics for all the
micro services are for an individual
service this particular dashboard proxy
performance
displays the total traffic success and
failure metrics there are out of box
reports and custom reports to get
various metrics like error code and
latency and more we have an API but we
don't have any in a way the developers
can start using it to create developer
apps to permit that let's create an API
provide from the apogee edge management
UI for this product we will call it as
take 5 product this is a place where the
API team can define the access level
settings quota settings including all of
the shipping service resources that the
developer applications can access this
is the ship's service name of the
shipping service and kubernetes
once the EPI product is created and
available developers can go to the
hipster shop developer portal to test
the API and create their apps let's look
at the API product and tracking API that
is published as there is no security
anyone that is logged in can access the
API and retrieve the tracking details in
this case the API team is unaware of who
is accessing the API and is unable to
enforce controls let's protect the API
this rule helps in safeguarding the
inbound traffic to the shipping service
with an API key as the next step we'll
apply the rule developers can't access
the API without a key which they can
negate by creating an app let's go back
to the developer portal login as a
developer create an app and access the
API
the supplication will be called as
hipster demo app and we'll copy the P
that is generated if you access the API
as a developer without a key it should
fail as we don't have the authorization
headers now let's make the same call
with the right-hander to be able to
retrieve the tracking details to the
successful response by doing all of this
you can see that Apogee is doing the API
key verifications security is enforced
and the API keys valid
great so with Apogee I can manage my API
so other developers can build
applications on top of mine exactly
Easter and Apogee can help you build
your application and make it too cool
for school if you liked what you saw
make sure to LIKE comment and subscribe
and if you'd like to get in contact with
us or know more about SEO Apogee and
micro services click on the links in the
description
[Music]